all right this is pretty cool
et Canada pride is getting freaky on the
phone with me are the boule brothers I
don't know if I'm allowed to say this or
not but
hello uglies is it okay for me to say
that hello we say that to you but it's
okay for this one and then yeah I mean I
wanted to turn the tables on you so I
mean first things first things first I
have to ask you both this how the heck
are you two so sick and twisted I love
it it totally comes natural it's
actually unavoidable it's one of the
traits that we were born with we've
we've spread and kind of like
meticulously sort of a harvested and now
we just enjoy every aspect of it we can
well season three of dragula premiered
earlier this week and fans can get their
freak on Tuesday nights on out TV and
they can catch up anytime on out TV go
and without TV go the little monsters
who can't wait for episodes will
actually be going up early how cool is
that
we love out TV they were the first
network to really believe in us and pick
us up and help develop so we love out TV
and everything they do it's a really big
deal for us Canadians here so I want to
thank you both for including our very
first Canadian on the show
Yaffe's kheh
I'm Yuka I'm 20,000 years old from
Toronto Canada your approach to drag
uses a lot of unconventional materials
but is it avant-garde or avant-garde
bridge it is absolutely our pleasure
she's young she has fresh imaginative
ideas I think she deserves a bigger
platform you know I think the thanks is
really better placed on her she's
creative she's a challenging artist and
it's our pleasure to give her a platform
for more people to see her yeah I mean I
was honestly I was blown away by all the
competitors on the series for season
three yob Scott and I mean I'm Canadian
so people may be like oh it's just a
Canadian thing but I am really excited
to see what she comes up with next yes
she does she has a lot of amazing looks
and she's a great spoiler for Madeline
Hatter
so Madeline I have to say well you guys
are also breaking down the barrier with
another first on the show which is
incredible we have the first drag King
on a North American reality show land
insider that is so cool why was now the
right time to include a drag king on
season three of dragula it's always been
about the Queens can you prove that
there's room for a king in this royal
family well I think the right time has
been always you know drag shouldn't be
owned by and isn't owned by one gender
and you know drag can include everybody
and it's something we wanted to include
on the show for a moment one but I think
fans and viewers were so not you know
used to the idea of everybody being
included in the beginning we didn't get
a lot of drag teams auditioning so it
just wasn't the right time now after the
show's had a little time to develop we
were able to go on tour and spread the
message that we are open to drag kings
and everything in between so it just
seemed like the right time to make it
work yeah and that's one thing I noticed
about watching season three last night
I'm like wow this has just become such
an inclusive show and it's really
helping to change the landscape of drag
or what people think of drag was that
really your intentions with creating the
show it sort of been our
mission since day one you know we
started doing nightlife events and
parties and our parties have always been
that way so dragula started as a
nightlife event in a pageant and in that
pageant we were open to everyone who
wanted to compete we are not here to
judge or drag drag is art and art is
subjective but we are judging you on is
your drag as it relates to this
competition and the challenges that we
put before you how fun is it to come up
with these bizarre ideas that are on the
series every week because I've read
every time every time i watch an episode
I'm like I'm actually a viewer at home
and I'm like oh my gosh I am so scared
of what's gonna happen well you know
what that is one the easiest part for us
and to the most thrilling it's probably
the thing that motivates us the boat so
I'm glad you enjoy it I think this show
with season three is you know it is if I
can say it it's the best that's ever
been and I think yeah well thank you
both for taking the time and talking to
me
and next time you're in Toronto I really
want you guys to come in studio and
we're gonna do something pretty sick and
twisted together how does that sound
that's so fun it the day alright it's a
day thank you so much and don't forget
to watch dragula season 3 on Oh TV and
streaming platform Oh TV go BIOS leave